hey dr. Burke here in this video we're
going to talk about apple cider vinegar
what are the benefits what are the myths
first of all here's the myth that
episode of immigrant Eanes a lot of
nutrients it really does not it doesn't
have a lot of vitamin A it doesn't have
a lot of vitamin C it doesn't have a lot
of minerals what it does have is
something even more important in fact
the real reason why apple cider vinegar
works for so many conditions has to do
with this one thing it has called acetic
acid that's an acid and then the reason
why it works is and this might go
against a lot of philosophies out there
is that the body most bodies that I come
I check in my office over many many
years are way too alkaline
now I know that goes against maybe what
you have heard that everyone's chup acid
but it's not true
you really have to when you talk about
pH you really have to understand that
every part of your body has a different
pH so if someone says oh yeah you're too
acid well what pH you talking about the
urine are you talking about the saliva
the real true indicator of pH for a body
should be in the blood but it's very
difficult to test that because soon as
you take the blood out of the body it
alkalized
it oxidizes and it can change the pH
right away so you have to it's very
expensive to determine that so you have
to go by symptoms and so if you ever
wanted to really now just look up in I
don't know Google it all the conditions
for two acid called acidosis and look up
for the conditions of alkalosis and all
those symptoms and you'll be able to see
which ones you have and you can
determine based on those two factors so
what we're talking about is the blood pH
here most people have a blood pH which
is excessively alkaline and yes it's
true that your blood should be slightly
alkaline but in this situation it
becomes even to Oakland okay and that's
why outside of integral works so well
because it changes if you change the pH
of your body just a slightly just a
slight bit you can create huge effects
because the pH is so important in
transporting minerals and allowing
enzymes to work to stimulating the
thyroid to increasing the table
all these things so let's just take a
deeper look at this one acid acetic acid
the pH of acetic acid is very acidic
it's 2.5 that's like almost like stomach
acid pH it's way down there so it's
really good for the stomach people take
it for heartburn and by the way
heartburn acid reflux indigestion that
is a condition where your stomach is too
alkaline and the valve on top does not
close and I know people say it's too
much acid no it's not fact that if you
have acid reflux or heartburn just take
some opposite of vinegar and see how
much better you feel I mean you'll feel
wonderful because the valve will start
closing on the top and the stomach the
acid won't start regurgitating up
through that valve so it's good for GERD
acid reflux indigestion okay and as you
age especially over the age of 50 60 70
your pH and your stomach starts going
lower I'm sorry it goes higher and
higher higher so it becomes more and
more alkaline so you need more acid as
you age to be able to digest protein and
absorb minerals because if your pH is
too alkaline which most people have a
problem with - too much alkaline they
can't absorb calcium they can't absorb
minerals like they used to so what
happens especially with calcium is
calcium starts building up in the soft
tissues throughout the body so you have
the soft tissue calcification I'm you
see them people are getting older
they're getting stiff they have
arthritis bursitis they get calcium
developing on the eyes as cataracts on
the joints is arthritis on the nerves
there's no Rytas on the kidney is kidney
stones on the gallbladders golf stones
and the teeth is tartar that could come
from a pH problem it's a alkalosis the
systemic alkalosis which is your whole
body is too alkaline
one of the things that I like to do as
well as make sure they're taking the
fats and vitamins to transport that
calcium out like vitamin D and k2 but in
this video we're going to talk about the
pH piece of this thing now what causes
this alkaline state it has to do with
this in this book it's called Sybil
encyclopedia of endocrinology volume for
frank net or MD this is one of the main
books that is used in medical schools
and it's a great physiology book to help
you
get some of the facts and how the body
works so right here if you look on the
page that talks about high cortisol
that's the stress hormone it talked it
high stress high cortisol causes
alkalosis it makes your body to alkyl
Lin so unless you don't live on planet
Earth you might not have this problem
but most people I know live on planet
Earth they have a lot of stress their
bodies become too alkaline
over time the worst thing you can do is
start drinking alkaline waters now it's
ok to drink water that's already
alkaline but don't try to alkalize it to
an eight or a nine or because you're
gonna make your body worse and then you
won't be able to absorb calcium and
things like that so with the Drina over
like stress in Kaikoura so you become
too alkaline and you lose this little
thing called H+ because if you ever
taken calcium I'm sorry chemistry
you'll notice that H H+ is an acid so in
other words the adrenal causes you to
lose acid through the urine and become
too alkaline so here's how all the
effects that stress can create an
alkaline body which then blocks calcium
so you have all this calcium that plugs
up everything but it's unavailable to
you so you start getting the twitch on
the left eye you ever notice when people
go get stress they have to start
twitching you know what that you know
what it is because it changes the pH and
the person can't absorb calcium so then
this is a calcium deficiency so you
could take calcium but if the pH isn't
right it won't work the best thing to do
if you have that twitch is to drink
outside of vinegar boom drop the pH to
make more acidic the calcium gets
mobilized and the twitch goes away
cramping in the calf outside the vinegar
is the best thing to mobilize the
calcium and get rid of cramping your
calf's nerve pain neuritis especially
like migraine pain with arthritis that
may be it a move from this joint to this
joint to this joint oh my gosh
give a little opposite of vinegar they
are happy so so with stress you become
too alkaline you lose acid and you lose
potassium and the only reason I'm
bringing up this potassium which is a
little extra thing is that
alkalyn bodies tend to have a potassium
loss and then when you lose potassium
you actually make the person more
alkaline so they kind of work together
you know people say well drink outside
vinegar to increase your potassium
that's not what's going to do it outside
of vinegar will help increase your
potassium because you'll stop losing the
potassium and you'll you'll make the
body more acidic and like it should be
and so that will help the potassium and
just think about look at this potassium
deficiency high blood pressure
constipation feeling of weakness fatigue
irregular heartbeats you know when you
hear these claims about app cider
vinegar hearing all these different
things high blood pressure constipation
weakness irregular heartbeats it's
because of the the retention of the
potassium because the a chain reaction
that occurs after getting the pH in the
correct level people that drink a lot of
protein drinks or they eat too much
protein let's say to do the Atkins diet
or they're doing this high-protein diet
what happens
there's the waste from that protein is
called guanidine it's a chemical very
very very very very alkaline okay and so
that can cause twitching nerve pain and
a lot of our thright as' okay even when
you do like the ketosis diet and you're
doing more protein
you may feel stiff you might feel more
arthritic drink some apple cider vinegar
it flushes this thing out so nicely so
apple cider vinegar is the antidote to
the residue of high protein but too much
protein for your liver and your body so
it's a really good cleanser so this acid
episode of vinegar helps absorb minerals
helps mobilize calcium helps you digest
protein better without the waste it
helps the immune system and that's the
last thing I want to talk about you've
heard that people will take out like
vitamin C for a cold right or for a
virus infection it's not the vitamin C
necessarily
it's creating the big effect because
most people aren't even taking about him
is he they're taking vitamin C
look-alike or a fake vitamin C it called
ascorbic acid which is not really true
vitamin C complex which I'll gano how
people disagree on this video because
they make you can make synthetic vitamin
C from ascorbic acid and cornstarch
first of all corn has no vitamin C corn
starch has no vitamin C skorpa caster's
nobody see how can you take two things
that don't have vitamin c mix them
together and make ascorbic acid and
think that's vitamin c it's just it's
fake the real benefit of vitamin C or
ascorbic acid is the acid you'd be much
better taking the acetic acid to help
your immune system if you get a cold if
you have a fever a viral infection start
taking the upside of vinegar it's really
really important so these are the true
benefits of opposite of vinegar because
it is Siddha Phi's an alkaline body so
in the next section I'm just going to
show you a little concoction that I make
and I drink on a regular basis okay so
let me show you how to make this this is
in my book chapter 10 it's called the
cranberry drink it should be called the
opposite of vinegar drink very simple
and you really should try this because
it will help you lose weight if you
drink one of these before you ate three
times a day you would lose a lot more
weight because it stimulates the thyroid
and it acidifies the stomach the only
thing that I would recommend if you if
you have a very slow metabolism as you
may want to omit the cranberry juice so
you get the Bragg's upset of vinegar
like this the best
and simply teaspoon in some water
actually do two to two spoons in the
water before each meal and some people
say don't consume water before a meal
but whereas it which this is an acid
drink so it's going to help stomach
acids but check this out this is it it's
my favorite lemon juice Italian volcano
lemon juice so organic lemon juice and
this stuff is magical it's wonderful
you get it from the helpers' store it's
grown on these these soils where are
these the volcanic ash fertilized the
soil so you just do a teaspoon of this
lemon right here you don't have to use
this lemon juice you can use other lemon
juice you can use lemons I like that
lemon juice because I'm spoiled
cranberry juice make sure you read the
back a label and it just comes from
whole cranberries because some people
get the one that has extra grape juice
or apple juice you don't want that just
do a teaspoon of this and basically this
is your drink now I like to and this is
just me you don't have to do this you
can add some ginger and there's some
ginger root that you can shred in there
and it makes it a little spicy
I basically have this ginger extract
that you can get it's a liquid form it's
like ginger juice and you put a little
ginger it's real spicy there's a lot of
great properties it's a very good tonic
again if you can't stand the taste
chances are you probably don't need it
okay if you really need it you will
crave it and it makes you feel better
but I really want you to try this real
simple drink this before you eat and
watch how much better you feel okay so
go ahead and do this and give me some
comments below I'll see you in the next
video